hey guys having a beard is awesome it's
cool i love it but there are a few
things that i really do not like about
having a beer
like brushing my teeth the toothpaste
always gets into my beard eating oats or
anything with a spoon it always ends up
on my beard
and itching your beard will itch if it
starts to grow longer and you don't take
good care of it
now a lot of guys they just go and they
shave their beard off just to get rid of
the itchiness
but don't do it don't be hasty just
relax be patient and watch this video
all the way to the end because i'm going
to give you tips to help you with your
itchy beard
[Music]
now the biggest reason why your beard
might be itchy is because it's dry the
skin underneath your facial hair is dry
so you gotta take good care of your beer
the first thing you need to do is get
good quality beard oil
all you got to do is just drip it into
your hand and just work it in there and
apply it every two to four days
depending on the condition of your beard
and skin now if you don't know anything
about beer products i'll add everything
you need to know in the video
description down below the best options
that i would recommend let's go to
number two wash your beard at least
every third day and this is important
when you wash your beard with beard
shampoo make sure you rinse it all the
way out and then when you are done
use beard conditioner you gotta use
beard conditioner and beard shampoo
products that are specifically made for
your beard don't use the same products
that you use for your hair because it's
different
don't keep your beard wet make sure you
dry it
oh yeah just in case you're near here
remember to subscribe and also click
that notification bell here so you will
be notified whenever i upload a new
video i would love the support from you
guys now let's go on to the next tip
number four use beard balm
just like beard oil beard balm is
awesome to keep your hair moisturized
and for us guys with the big beards that
look like this right if you don't style
it it will help you to style your beard
as well
tip number five clean your beard brush
or your comb whatever you have whatever
you like to use remember to clean it
every week
if you use the same brush or comb every
week without cleaning it it's going to
get dirty and get bacteria all over it
and then you go and put that brush
through your whole beard no wonder it
gets itchy now if you want more grooming
tips stay on my channel check out these
videos here and i'll see you there
cheers guys